what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
april 5th from the heart of
[__] new jersey
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen
it's april and that means it's time for
the biggest
golf tournament of the year the masters
the best golfers in the world are still
all down in augusta georgia
getting ready to compete in that little
with their little green jackets on
you want to get into that green get
draftkings
they're america's top-rated sportsbook
app and this week
they're giving you 100 to one odds if
the golfer you pick
ends up in the top 10. are you crazy
it's a hole in one turn one dollar into
pick any golfer from this weekend's
tournament
if they finish in the top 10 you get 100
that's it and if your finances are in
the sand trap
draftkings will put your back on top
listen to me
we got nba this week we got [__]
baseball
think i saw something about if you put a
dollar down on a hit and hits a home run
that's the action draftkings is giving
you this week
so sign up for the draftking sportsbook
app right now
choose the golfer before the tournament
tease off
thursday morning draftkings is safe
secure
and reliable you withdraw with your
money whenever you want
so do me a favor drown download the
draftking sports book app today right
now
monday morning [__] tip top magoo use
promo code
joey when you sign up to turn 100 into a
hundred a dollar
into 100 if the golfer of your choosing
finishes in the top 10 of this weekend's
tournament again if golf ain't your [__]
they got another they got nba
they got baseball i mean they got back a
rock they got casinos
that's draft king sportsbook app now
download it
code joey to turn a dollar into 100
for a limited time only at
draftkingsportsbook now
here's the fine print you got to be 21
old okay i don't know what to tell you
go [__] play hopscotch
new jersey indiana pa only new customers
only
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details again if you got
a gambling problem
this might not be for you okay call
1-800 gambler
or in indiana call 1-809 with it but
if you're [__] straight this is for
you
you can't go over your head you can have
fun
you can keep it low and just [__]
entertain yourself for watching the
games
during the last couple weeks before you
get [__] and
let out into the jungle into the mass
exodus of life
download the draftking sports book app
use code joey
the joint is also brought to you by blue
chew
spring is in the air be ready for when
love comes your way
make sure your confidence when it counts
with blue
chew listen blue chew combats all forms
of vd i don't give a [__] what you do
i don't give a [__] if you snort a pound
of coke you drop a blue chew it's got
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis at a fraction of the cost
blue chew brings you the first
chewable dick pill this ain't no [__]
you know
snake juice from [__] bolivia that
your friend smuggled in his nutsack
this is science [__] the process
is simple
sign up at blueshoot.com and talk to one
of their licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
it shipped right to your door in a
discreet package
and listen nobody knows nothing not even
the mailman
they got a special deal for you this
week blue chew you ready
try blue chew for free joey what are you
talking about try blue chew for free use
promo code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's all i'm asking out of you
go to bluetooth right now type it in
bluetooth b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w
dot com promo code joey to receive your
first month
for free and as always i want to thank
blue shoe for sponsoring the podcast but
i want to thank you guys for taking
advantage of it because even if you
don't have ed
you want to show up like [__] rambo
and rambo too remember
he showed up with the arrows [__]
blowing up people
that's what you want to do so do me a
favor download
go to bluetooth.com use promo code joey
and get the first one for free
that's it the joint is also brought to
you by
you ready for this one you're gonna love
it stamps.com
listen to me you could spend all day
[__] online at the post office
you're wasting time money and energy now
is it not the time to be standing online
at the post office
or anywhere else that's why my wife and
i use stamps.com
you can send letters ship packages
anytime anywhere
right from your computer with stamps.com
you get a discounted rate
from usps ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours
and stacks of cash my wife loves it
listen she just weighs them puts prints
out the stamps
puts them on the post on the box and you
leave them outside and the mailman picks
them up it's that easy
if you're a small business owner
stamps.com is a must-have
print any u.s postage for any letter any
package any class mail
it's no wonder why a million small
businesses are already using stamps.com
so stop wasting time going to the post
office people breathing on your neck you
don't need that just go to stamps.com
instead
there's a no risk you use promo code
joey and you get a special offer listen
to me
it includes a four-week trial plus free
postage
and a digital scale no learning no long
long-term commitments and contracts here
just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in joey that's
stamps.com
promo code joey stamps.com never go to
the post office again
let's kick this party off it's monday
morning why mess around
we got a lot to talk about
candles are lit [__] let's start
this
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday morning
april 5th a beautiful [__] day to be
alive
hopefully you [__] had a great
weekend you know what i'm saying i had a
great time i didn't do much
uh saturday we had an easter egg hunt
you know with the kids in the
neighborhood
sunday was easter i went over the
jimmies
and uh today i'm putting the podcast up
and i got good news for you [__]
i'm getting my covet shot i know half
ears are on the [__] whatever listen
don't make no [__] remarks because
i'm doing the johnson johnson
it's one [__] shot i'm in and out of
there
and i'll live with that i wear my mask
you gotta wait two weeks
to [__] let it get in there once they
told me that i'm like what the [__] i
gotta wait more time now
i gotta hunt down the shot now i gotta
wait more time
but anyway listen it's over i know a lot
of you guys are going joey do the
[__] mcdonald's do me a favor who
gives a [__]
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna take care of
this and i'm gonna tell you something
just so you know
just so you know [__] okay
because a lot of times it's like when i
got locked
up i could have beat that case because i
could have told them the truth and
told them i went to the dentist and i
got gas that morning
and i didn't know what i was doing and
they could have maybe thrown it up and i
could have beat it but that's not the
case i'm beating it
i wanted i wanted to get what was coming
to me that's what's coming to me what do
you what do you want me to do
if i beat it then i was going to be on
the [__] wrong side of karma the rest
of my [__] life
you want me to tell you something
somebody already approached me and said
you don't need to [__] get a card
i got an extra one here for you that's
signed and everything sealed and
delivered with two [__] modernist
shots
you're in new jersey what do you think
was gonna happen you don't think people
are gonna already have cards printed up
i could have paid the [__] small 50
bucks and had a card i'm telling you the
truth
but you know what it's just not an
example for you guys
because if i'm gonna [__] talk to
talk i gotta walk the walk it's time to
stop [__] chucking and driving like
that [__] prosecutor told me a friend
of mine came through i called a couple
people
you know what i'm saying like i listen
you guys know i'm a [__] [__] when
it comes to that [__]
if i do the modern the first time and i
[__] faint and go into [__]
convulsions and i fall down
you guys know i'm not gonna go back no
28 days later you guys know that right
so
let's just take the one i'll take uh
[__] heist to my arm whatever
uh a friend of mine said he'll give me a
[__] happy pill
that he's got up at the [__] house uh
my
sister's going with me lisa is gonna go
with me actually
i'm also taking another buddy with me
that i grew up with because
the guy who got us the shots grew up
with us so
it was perfect it was a perfect [__]
deal i'm over 55.
my friend's over 55. listen guys it
sucked for me
for [__] five weeks to go somewhere
and for somebody to email you two days
later i'll call you
and say somebody had [__] covered you
gotta go get the only [__] test i
took
i'm up to here i'm up to i put more
[__] q-tips in my nose and i did
straws and i did coke for
27 [__] years like i'm done guys
but that's why i'm doing the shot so
whatever you may feel
feel whether you agree with me you don't
what can i say somebody's always got a
[__] uh opinion
anyway on the bright side i want to talk
to you guys about something you know
when i got into comedy i got into comedy
in in uh
february of 91. before that i took a
course for three weeks a class for three
weeks three hours a sunday
then i got a job at a comedy club to
learn the
ins and outs of the dynamics and in the
meantime
i watched every stand-up special i could
get my hands on
before i went up on stage so i was
[__]
prepared when i
picked up the guitar a couple weeks ago
mike gave me the guitar listen
i got 50 people that could teach me i
got uh
i go on youtube and learn i know i don't
have the aptitude
and i know that if i just have a friend
teach me i won't take it seriously
i won't look at him seriously i'm the
type of guy that has to pay for it
because i'm a [__] cuban jew
and i know that if i pay for it then
i'll [__] pay attention to every
[__] minute
but that's what works for me some people
could just go online and learn stuff for
me
i always want to be a little bit
prepared i always want to read a little
bit more about it when i go lift i know
how to lift i've been lifting since i
was a [__] kid
but now i'm getting a little older i
want to do other things
so i i lift with a [__] private
little [__] dude that [__] make
sure
my form is right yeah he makes sure my
form is right
he makes sure that i'm [__] not going
to pass out he makes sure i'm not going
to throw my back out you know you always
want to be prepared to what you want to
do
when podcasting came along what about is
there any books on podcasting
have you seen any maybe now that's 10 11
12 years later
that people haven't been podcasting but
there was nothing i was thrown to the
wolves
i learned from listening to [__] uh
mark maron
and joe rogan and then i said wait a
second let me do something
let me listen let me listen to because i
knew radio was on the way down no
offense to people on radio
i just knew that radio was going down so
what i did was
i started listening to marin and joe
rogan religiously
while i did my podcast with felicia but
i also
drove a subaru which comes with serious
radio most cars do
they come with serious radios so i got
to listen to jim norton
on ozzie's boneyard and you know [__]
eddie trunk and i got to listen to jimmy
florentine
and the other guy keith whatever on
ozzie's boneyard and
i also went dug deep and
went into the old howard stearns with
artie lange
because i felt that that was the best
period of
of how it's turned that's just my
opinion i know a lot of you guys are
going to tell me to go [__] myself or
whatever but i just feel that
there was a couple of dark years there
with with artie lang
that i really enjoyed listening to it
when he would tell his stories
i really thought it would captivate it
so not that joey is a thief or an idea
thief
i hybrid that so another guy that i took
from
was a guy named eddie trunk i listened
to eddie trunk and i realize that to
have a podcast
and to do certain things you have to
have patience
so my inspirations for podcasting came
from listening to radio as a young kid
you know
wbls the chicken on naw
and then as i got older when 93 and i
lived in new york
i listened to stern and you know this
was i think way before already
but it was [__] just outrageous type
radio you know
[__] uh yeah the little guy from
public enemy
when he told uh when the when when
howard stern asked him that hey man i
heard you know this is 1993 it's a
different time
is before oj killed his wife so uh the
little guy from
howard stern asked the little guy from
[__]
public enemy not chuck d but whatever
his name is
he said to him what's going on with you
i heard you got in trouble
for hating your wife don't you know that
women have rights and he goes i got
lefts
you know and i was like what the [__] i
started laughing my ass off and
you know not that it's funny but at the
time the joke was funny
and i thought that that out i wanted
that outlandishness
i wanted the darkness that artie gave
to stern
and i also wanted the positivity
of eddie trunk i wanted those three i
wanted to combine that
and that's what i think i do the only
thing i don't do that eddie does
is take calls i don't have that much
[__] patience
so what i did was i i really did
listen to eddie for a long time and i
fell in love with him
um when i would come to new york i tried
to get on the show i didn't
i didn't know who to call i was too
embarrassed to call florentine
anybody i mean i just related to him on
so many different levels
except that eddie doesn't get high so
eddie knew about
all this [__] music and he's
basically a sober cat that maybe has a
drink from once in a while and loosens
up he's a family man
but his knowledge of music made me
jealous
and that's why i got dean delray in
there to do music podcasts so
you know all when you see me doing
something it's because i i've
paid attention to a lot of things and
taken them into one
simple enough let's just simplify it on
the podcast today
we got to be trunk i was lucky enough to
get him to have a zoom call
with me once i got the jersey i did a
show at uncle vinnie's one night he
showed up and we had a great talk so i
got an opportunity to bring him on the
show
do me a favor enjoy me and eddie trunk
thank you for watching guys what's
happening mr trump you're looking good
with the little new hairdo
that's called just that's called what's
left of the hair coming out of the
shower
congratulations on your vaccine you're
[__] fully vaccinated that's it
did you get it yet not yet i'm waiting
for johnson johnson you know i'm a
[__]
[__] i hate needles oh is that right oh
i [__] hate needles i
just had the surgery i had enough
needles for the [__] yeah i have like
a quota for needles for the years
they took i don't know how many stitches
they gave me i don't know how many
needles they gave me
i got the one in the [__] spine the
block
oh oh so you got to give me a breather
with needles for a couple of weeks like
right now
you had that though this is nothing
really
it's a little let me tell you um
the thing it's funny because when i got
the first shot
the guy said to me um when he gave it to
me
it was like two not even two seconds it
was like big pink i didn't even know he
did it
and i said to him i go uh man you're
good i felt like nothing and he goes to
me yeah he goes
i don't know what these people are doing
on tv he goes they're making it look
like it's this big procedure he goes and
they're like gone like this and
the needle looks like this he goes
they're doing a big wind up and [__]
because it's nothing he goes it's like
and i go yeah it really was he goes yeah
they're trying to make it more dramatic
when they know
there's a camera on them but it's really
not it's nothing it's it's really
nothing your arm's going to be a little
sore for a couple days i mean
i had my wife just got the second she
had the same one as i did the moderna
and we had uh we both had the same thing
like for about 20
12 hours after the shot for about 24
hours you feel like [__]
you sluggish maybe a light fever but
24 hours later you're good my wife just
had it on saturday
which one so she did the modern and i
just watched her
her evolution she did that like two in
the afternoon
and by eight i could see her face she
started to get a little pale we came
home me and my daughter watched the
honeymooners and uh
all in the family that's our ritual on
saturdays nice
and my wife passed on it she's like i
gotta go to bed
yeah sunday she felt a little sluggish
she did some stuff and then she went
down like at five
yeah and then yesterday she was men's
and mortar day like
but so far so good i'm going to do the
johnson and johnson i've called a couple
different
you know because it's made in jersey and
we can't [__] find them in jersey
yeah how the [__] is that it's right in
east brunswick and i can't get it
nowhere
so i've made calls but forget vaccine
talk
i want to [__] welcome you to uncle
joey's [__] joint this is
an honor for me to have eddie trunk on
you don't know
what you mean to me how you've helped me
be a better podcaster i wish
you knew how many hours i spent
listening to you in the [__] car
driving on the 405.
and i always tell people my expression
is you have to have the patience of
trunk of eddie trunk i remember telling
florentine that
for the first time they died of laughter
i go nobody has the patience
of eddie trunk he handles the heavy
metal guys
with gloves like i've never [__] seen
when they call you
that is the funniest cause and they
always have a southern accent
you always get a redneck that calls you
and say hey eddie
man they used to be the band called
speed trap 19 and then
you would [__] i remember them they
put out a small album
i don't know why they couldn't you know
like you just [__] know everything
but it's always rednecks that caught you
it's never like a guy from jersey going
hey eddie what the [__] is going on here
it's so good i guess those dudes i get i
get those i listen to those
i mean that that's the cool thing about
doing a live daily radio show that's the
national broadcast is you know
you're gonna get and i'm very aware of
that you know you get people in new york
or l.a you're gonna get people in
arkansas and oklahoma
and everybody's gonna have a different
view and a different uh
feeling about stuff and be in different
a different situation so i try to
you know i try to give everybody equal
time and a shot and then we got the
canadians that call in because
siriusxm is on in canada too so you get
them and they're always the nicest
people in the world
so you learn everybody's you know
everybody's thing based on where they're
from
i would sit there and listen to you and
it was the same thing with florentine i
rekindled i met florentine in 97.
to me he was just jim florentine i liked
him because he lived in weehawken at the
time
and i'm a hudson county boy so we became
kind of friends
we reacquainted ourselves over the 2000s
little by little jimmy how you doing
bubba i see him in l.a
on sundays my daughter would go to
church with my wife
and i would have this time in the
mornings and it would be you
and jimmy and i would listen to jimmy
and one day he's describing
an iron maiden concert in asbury park
it was judas priest and the iron maiden
was opening up for them
i was there july of 81 probably yeah
and i'll never forget this like i have
been here uh
eight months now and i have not gone to
asbury park
and i will tell you why i hear it's
beautiful but last time i went to asbury
park
we got out of the car we closed the
doors it was a z28
we didn't even turn around and some guy
threw a bottle at us
it was judas priest iron maiden and
that's when jimmy florentine lit the
smoke bomb
i was going to a couple heavy metal
concerts and i kept realizing that
somebody kept lighting [__] smoke
bombs
at these heavy metal concerts and one
sunday i'm driving and it's jimmy
telling a story about iron maiden
when he lit the [__] smoke bomb and
they caught him
and his mother had to go get him and his
eyes were red so his mother asked him
you know he was stoned
and i've heard your stories about
concerts and i mean
we all grew up in jersey we're all about
the same age we all went to the same
[__] concerts
and here you are on the east coast i'm
on the west coast i'm like
i can't wait to meet this [__] guy
because
he knows everything about music
and you know and that's why when we met
for the first time just recently when i
came to your comedy show at uncle
vinnie's
couple two three months ago i mean that
you know
people like us we're from the same area
like you said around the same age
the same things it's it's weird i find
like even if
even though that was the first time i
was really meeting you i felt like i
knew you forever
it was amazing when you're you know kind
of cut from the same cloth and come from
the same world
we probably were probably in the same
line waiting for concerts i
you know i used to go to hole in the
wall i used to go to
uh the one the bubble factory the soap
factory
to see uh i saw aerosmith at the soap
[__] aerosmith no joe perry rocky
whispered yeah terrible they were
horrible it was a nightmare
i used to go i never saw bon jovi in
jersey but i saw
the good rats all those old jersey bands
you know sticky fingers
they were all like covered joey how old
are you 58.
so you got two years on me and that's a
big
two years because you caught
that period of time where the before the
probably before the drinking age changed
yeah because for me every time all my
friends were a couple years older than
me
and it was always like they were always
like would you hurry up and be 18 so you
can get in the clubs and then jersey
moved it to 19
then the 20 then 21 every time i got a
year from
close to the drinking age they moved it
a year later so i didn't get to go like
i remember going down to the jersey
shore i mean i still got a place down in
ortley
and uh i walked to seaside heights
boardwalk and that's where i won
all these records as a kid and i
remember there was a
bar on the boardwalk called the
chatterbox and i used
i used to stand outside of that bar as a
kid and just listen because they always
had the door open to the band playing
and like dream of what it would be like
to be in there and actually be at the
bar watching the band
they kept moving the drinking age a year
later on me until finally you know i hit
21. but if you were able to catch it
sounds like a little bit of that tail
end of the jersey club scene too
i thought i caught the tail end i went
to cbgb's
as a [__] 13 year old because
jersey didn't have pictures on your
license
right so if any trunk had a brother
named mikey trunk
eddie me and eddie were [__]
criminals we stole eddie trunks we stole
mikey trunks id
correct so we they had no paper they had
no picture on them
and the only thing the guy would ask you
is what your sign is
like if he you oh yeah young and they
would go what sign are you
that's how they would [__] with you
there was no paper they couldn't prove
it that it wasn't you
so i still remember going to see a buddy
of mine took me to see the police
at cbgb's and you know
nobody knew nothing i went nobody said
anything
you know it was like accepted so that's
the only way i got in to go
see those bands that young was because
of fake ids from jersey
yeah i couldn't do the bars and the
clubs because i was just missing that
like i missed
the whole the whole twisted sister thing
when they were so big in the clubs and
i missed all that because i was just too
young but what i did do was i would go
to a lot of shows that were happening
like
in theaters and stuff where you didn't
have to be drinking age
so i saw metallica with mistain still in
the band
open for uh the rods in vandenberg
metallic uh kirk hammett's first show
with metallica
was at a place that is only about 10
minutes from where i live now
in dover in a place called the show
place and i saw all kinds of metal shows
there
and kirk's first show with the band i
was at that and that was there as well
interestingly it just went up for sale
kurt kirk should buy it just for the
history he has there but
it's uh yeah so i would always go to
shows like that until i was legal
drinking agent get into clubs
jimmy showed me some places off the nine
where he saw metallica like he told me
matisse on the top
what's metallica's love with new jersey
in these small places
tons well jim jim used to go to club 516
that's probably the place he showed you
that's was one of the places
and then jim used to work at the birch
hill which is now
condos or something but the bird show
was a great spot
uh because uh there were a ton of shows
there in the 80s and even in the early
90s i even saw like marilyn manson there
so it was going
for a pretty long time but so so jim
would have seen
stuff like that but metallica had huge
roots in new jersey even though they
were west coast because
the guy who signed them and put out
their first two records
johnny z on his company megaforce was
based in old bridge
so he relocated them to the new york new
jersey area to make their first record
and while he had him here put them in a
house in old bridge
he had them work the clubs and play gigs
wherever you could get them in the area
so they have huge roots uh in new jersey
and very very much tied to it from the
from the earliest days
and then the crazy story about that is i
ended up
how i got my job where i worked for
megaforce records for johnny and his
label from 86 to 90.
and how i got that gig was that in 83
when i started in radio johnny drove to
my metal show that i was doing on wdha
had this record by this band i only knew
johnny because he had a store in a flea
market a record store i said what are
you doing at the studio
so you got this record nobody will touch
this band nobody will play this
he said will you will you please um
do me a favor and give it a shot it was
the first metallica record
so i played it yeah i played it nobody
knew what it was
i played the song just because he was
standing there i i was only on the radio
like three months
at that point i was right out of high
school and he left and he said to me
if i can ever get this bad to happen and
get my record label that they're on off
the ground i'm gonna come back i'm gonna
hire you
yeah yeah yeah i didn't know what that
was gonna happen and then three years
later he calls me up
he says i got good news i got bad news
the good news is
you know metallica took off they left
they went to a label i got a big
settlement
i got money i'm good to go we're going
to start the label
officially i want to hire you the bad
news is you won't be working with
metallica because they're leaving me
that's how i'm getting the money i said
great and i went to work for him for
four years so
indirectly taking a chance early on on
metallica
and noah johnny and him being of his
word that's how he ended up working for
him and doing a label thing
i always still did radio but but i had a
full-time job at that point doing label
stuff
have you always been a metal guy
i would definitely say hard rock you
know metal metals uh
metal is a very broad term to somebody
now
metal would would be like stuff that i
don't even listen to like metals got so
extreme and
things have changed but you could go to
somebody and say the term metal and they
think
bon jovi and def leopard are metal and
then you know slayers metal and this
so i always loved metal but i love the
more traditional metal
like we talked about priest made in
metallica what have you
but uh i'd say what better probably
classifies
what i like now just because metal has
moved into a more extreme direction
would be probably more accurately called
hard rock but
hard rock rock metal i've always i've
always had to have some guitars some
edge some some
some there's really you know very little
music outside of that that i personally
listen to
i've always been at my core a rock guy
now the other thing that you and i agree
on that
when i heard you say it i almost crashed
my [__] car
because i have felt strongly about this
album
for years and nobody would hear my cries
i'm like a domestic woman a domestic
violence victim that gets beat up and
nobody hears my cries
is ufo strangers in the night you and i
both agree on the same page that that is
one of the best live albums of all time
i listened to it two nights ago out of
respect for you because i was gonna
see you what what is it
what do we classify ufo is that heavy
metal
is that metal is that just
brilliance hard rock okay that's that's
the best way
schenkner on that album does things
that it's what jimmy page did at the
garden
to that guitar during the song remains
the same i mean
you and i are in agree i've heard you
over and over discuss it
with different people what is it about
that album
uh it may be is my favorite album of all
time
i think it's definitely one or two of
the among the one
two or three of the greatest live albums
ever made
i i i just i
i it's hard to say because we're talking
about a band now that i
absolutely love as you said you love and
they never became a household name in in
america
but they have their fans outside of
america they're
way bigger actually more people know
them
they had a huge influence on bands like
metallica iron maiden and all these
bands that went on to greater things but
i think what i love so much about them
is i always liked joey
melody with my heaviness so i always
liked great singing
i always liked melody hooks i along with
great guitar and just great energy
and to me no band
has ever done melodic hard rock better
than ufo
the vocals the songs the guitar playing
everything listen to a song like love to
love that song
it takes you it's it it's mellow and
then it punches you in the gut
and then it's got the great guitar
melody and then cool
and it's just incredible what a
beautiful opening on that live album
it's a beautiful opening love to love i
mean
and that live album so prior to that
the studio recordings of all those songs
are really good
but it was when they put it all together
and did that live
and the energy it's funny because i've
talked to the band about it many times
and they're amazed because people who
love rock music
even though it's not a mainstream thing
that everybody knows
most people that are hardcore rock fans
do worship that record
and the band is fascinated by it and
they acknowledge that
it's often comes up in the top greatest
live records ever
but the thing that they find so funny
about it is at that time
they were like coked up out of their
mind
they were like that was like the height
of them drinking and drugging and
everything
and they don't really i understand how
they found them
found their way to the stage let alone
played that well that night
and it's really a live record you know
so many live records got went in they
doctored them they recorded them
i talked to the guy who produced it it's
pretty much a completely live record
and that's another thing that i think
you really feel in that that it's not a
studio record
with applause that's really how it went
down
it's uh it's one of my favorites i love
ufo
what's i can't you know so much has gone
on recently that
what's the album with one more for the
rodeo on it
that's my special that's a great [__]
album that is
that is one of my i love him as a guitar
player you know i
it's so funny how i my first live album
was get yaya's out by the stones
i did not like it i did not like it
you know then ted came along i like
ted's double live gonzo
i love i've been looking for frank
marino's live album i've been listening
to that lately i saw them at the
meadowlands
in 78 and they've never you know
uh it's so weird when i read keith
richards book
he said he spoke about how we've
forgotten how to make live music
there's no more live albums you know we
our age group at least we got so many
great
live albums even aerosmith's live album
great bad isn't bad no i love it super
underrated and
totally real because it's all radio
broadcasts i i i think bootleg is a
tremendously
underrated life i think it's underrated
yeah i saw them live a couple times i
wasn't happy with them
i saw joe perry open up for heart at
radio city
and they were okay you know joe perry
was going through his [__] dilemmas
at the time
but uh i think bootleg is great i i i
think are you ever a kiss fan
jelly yes no it's not alive
i think it's [__] phenomenal i think
it's great i've heard you talk about
i had a dear friend that we were friends
in the eighth grade
and were both kiss fans and he died
so i took the three kiss albums that i
had and i put him in the [__]
funeral casket and i said next time we
had kiss we'll listen to it together so
yeah lately the last three years i've
broken down a little bit
and i because i love rock and roll
whatever what's that
the one album rock and roll rock and
roll oh
i love it i remember i want you i love
and then i
love destroyer is a [__] monster
and kiss alive is just a [__] monster
you know but it's weird how the
people today i feel bad for them because
they didn't get to experience
these live albums like we did we really
were right there
you would get to live um and then go see
the band or whatever you know
we don't have that no more like the
people growing up today nobody you know
you might get a bootleg recording or
something but there's really no live
music are you excited for this summer to
go out again and
see shows and are you ready
yeah i look i don't unfortunately i
don't think we're going to get big shows
this year at all
i think we're going to get shows that
will be
more uh theater maybe reduce theater
club shows that i think will come back
i think maybe towards the back end of
the year we'll get a couple festivals
hopefully in certain parts of the
country
but i don't think we're going to get
like the outdoor sheds or the
arenas or certainly the stadiums back
until next year
i you know being in jersey i drove by
the down the garden state parkway the
other day
and every year you go by for people
not in the jersey area our local
amphitheater is called
it's called now pnc bank arts center it
used to be garden state art center
that's what we all know it has
but the signs there you know right on
the parkway and it always shows you
around this time it scrolls all the
events and concerts they're gonna have
there
and there was nothing there's nothing on
the board so i don't
i don't think we're gonna get the shows
back the way we want them for
probably another year but i am
optimistic and excited
because i am seeing encouraging signs
i'm seeing some things being announced
uh look i don't make all my living on
the road
but i make a good amount of extra living
on the road out there hosting stuff and
going to shows
and involved being involved with shows
so i took a big hit the last year
without a lot of shows going on
and the good news is starting like uh
first weekend of may
i've got stuff coming in where like hey
we want you to come to texas or oklahoma
or
sacramento or north dakota like it's all
like throwing a dart
but it's it's cool that's starting to
come back online a little bit and i'm
gonna go do it so
i think the signs are encouraging but i
think unfortunately the bigger the band
meaning the more amount of people if you
want to see ac dc i don't think you're
going to see that for another year at
least
because it's just you can't fill a
stadium right now
what's going on with the motley crew
tour i heard that they put out a few
dates they're coming to new jersey i
know i went to p
i went on a pnc schedule and i saw
steely dan
for july the 3rd and i'm like
how the [__] unless the elite dan does
of pnc i don't know what pnc seats
10 000 maybe i mean i think the other
thing about it is look if
they're not going to open that building
for the summer just for stealing dan
obviously
they had other people on the schedule if
you go online right now
you'll see that they have people on
their schedule is that right
yeah because there was nothing on the
marquee when i went by it the other day
and they usually always scroll
the stuff coming up so i i don't know i
think there's a lot of people
just trying to i think some of the
promoters are really concerned to to go
all
in and announce the show and put it on
sale because it was such a nightmare a
year ago when they started to have to
processing the refunds
and rescheduling and everything so i
think everybody is like really gun shy
about jumping in until they know what
they can do because you and i both know
from being out there and for
of course what you do out there as a
comic i mean you know that
for some of these places uh you can't
you can't do a reduced capacity because
the economics don't work unless the
artist
is willing to take a hit on the money
because the promoter can't pay the
artist the same amount
that he if he could sell 10 000 seats if
he can only sell 2 000
and if the artist might not want to go
do it for that reduced amount of money
and just wait it out
so it's just it's the wild west i mean
people are just trying to figure
it all out now you just heard the other
day they're saying you might have to
show a vaccine card or
vaccine passport in order to get into
these places and
there's people chirping about that so i
don't know i think everybody's figuring
it out
you have seen some people that have
routed some shows figured out a way to
route 20 shows
because you also know and most people
know there's a huge difference between
doing a show
or doing a weekend and touring
in order to tour you got to be able to
do five six shows a week to make it make
sense financially right but if you're
a smaller band and you can fly in and do
a weekend and fly out
and rent gear then maybe you can make
that work
but i don't think to answer your
question before that motley def leppard
tour
there's a lot of blow back about that
because a year ago
everyone on the planet knew that that
was not going to be able to happen
and live nation didn't pull the plug on
it and announce it until like a week
before the first show
and people were pissed because they had
their money tied up
and people didn't know what was going to
happen and they wanted refunds if they
needed them
that was handled really poorly well here
we are
about to turn april the first date of
that supposed to take place in florida
in june
i don't think there's any rational
person on the planet and i really i
really hope i'm wrong joey i don't want
to be pessimistic
but i'm just realistic there's anybody
on the planet that thinks
that they'll be able to do full stadium
shows this summer
just not gonna happen just look at
sports that mets opening day is only
gonna have eight thousand out of fifty
thousand there they can't do it
so what are you gonna do if the building
is if all the tickets are sold to 40 000
people we're going to go to 30 000 of
them and say
you can't come even though you have a
ticket what are you going to do go to
the band and say we know you're paying
your ex but now we're going to pay a
quarter of that
it don't work it doesn't work so they're
gonna just have to move it
into next year again they haven't
announced anything yet
but uh look let's be honest too these
promoters
if they can hold on to your money for a
year or two don't hold on to it
you're not seeing the interest they are
they tried to do it
on a comic level like i told everybody
cancel
and they were like no we're moving the
dates that's what they were getting away
with
we're moving the dates so we're not
gonna give you your money back i turned
around and said
give them their [__] money back now
that's the way to do
it now now don't worry there's a couple
there's a couple rock bands that did
that
bon jovi did it leonard skinner did
i think alice and chains gave them their
money back not allison chains uh
uh rager gets a machine i think i think
i'm not sure
but they were holding on to their money
until we canceled it officially
yeah i kept getting people hitting me up
going hey man you're still selling
tickets
in this place and i was like no i'm not
that's cancelled
and i had to call the club personally
and tell them to give them their [__]
money back cut this [__]
give them their [__] money back and
they did eventually you know
yeah i had a guy call my radio show like
two three days ago
i forget where he was in the country and
he goes hey eddie he goes great news man
i just i just bought a couple tickets to
the motley leopard show
he goes in a couple weeks in a couple
months i'm so excited or whatever i go
what'd you do that for he goes well they
where tickets are on sale i go well of
course they're going to sell them to you
because once they got you you're going
to have to go through a song and dance
if you can't go
or they want to hold your money for a
year that's the whole thing you know
can you imagine the amount of interest
that you can make on
receipts for a tour that's you know
forty thousand fifty thousand tickets a
night for how many dates i mean
sitting in an account escrow somewhere
for two three years
that's that's real money so of course
they want to sell you right up to the
second and then pull it
so you just i tell people all the time
like just
open your eyes man if you're okay and
you're in a financial situation where
you're okay having that happen
that's fine but there's some people as
we all know whoever have had a rough
year here
lost work lost their jobs or whatever
you don't want to have your money tied
up and trying to fight to get it back
it's ridiculous if you're
if you're trying to deal with that right
now well i'll tell you one thing
like i don't know if you noticed the ufc
sold out an event in florida
15 000 seats
in 31 minutes or some [__] like that
so i think i think that poison
motley crew and all those bad def
leopard on that tour
they're gonna be faced with this
question florida's gonna let you do it
texas is gonna let you get together but
how many other states are gonna let you
get together
so they're gonna look at that and go so
we got 12 states to let us get together
what did new jersey announce today
we could we could 200 people get
together
20 over 25 2500 plus building
yeah so it's not going to happen we're
not going to happen here so it's
tours are not going to happen it doesn't
it doesn't work joey
your thing what you said is true so even
if they said
uh for a tour like the motley leopard
thing
okay yeah you could do texas you can do
florida
you could do oklahoma you can do
arkansas whatever
you can't put a production like that
together no
hired crews buses planes all the [__]
you need the staging
to do five shows when you're supposed to
do 40. it doesn't
the economics don't work for anybody so
it can't be
that's why the club level theater level
stuff you can if you're a smaller band
fly in and do something you know i had
the guitar player from iron maiden on my
show the other day
and that's a huge band internationally
obviously and i said to him
i said he he was on promoting a solo
side thing that he's doing
and i said to him i said adrian i said
this is great timing for you
because you're going to have at least a
year before iron maiden can play
you can now take this and go into the
clubs and have some fun and play if you
want to
because you got a window because you're
you know you you're cursed if there's
such a thing of being in such a big band
but since you have something that you
could play a club with
you could still get out there and have
some fun and promote this and he agreed
he said you're right
so that's the thing if you're a rock fan
you want to see some weekend shows or
some stuff in clubs and theaters
you'll probably be able to see that but
the big stuff i think it's next year
at the soonest personally i hope i'm
wrong i'd love to see something happen i
mean i
i host a festival in tulsa outside of
tulsa every year i've been doing it
since 07
called rock oklahoma it's a big
three-day thing and that's on schedule
to happen
and they normally do it memorial weekend
but they moved it to labor day weekend
so now we're a little later so they feel
good about that
i feel good about that again that's
oklahoma and it's outside
so it should be okay i know the eagles
went on sale
but they also went on sale for september
right i think that tour went on sale for
september
straight and i think by that time things
will be a little lightened up more
we know it will be i don't know how many
people will want to be inside
even with a vaccine you don't know
i mean this is all we're looking into
the unknown you know
right just happy that they have a
vaccine available
and that we're going into the right
direction for performers you know i want
i want to see live music again
especially now i'm in jersey close to
you and the florentines and
i know how much you guys love music i'm
in like i'm in
but i doubt a band like guns you're not
going to see them
for a year and a half hooks was a pain
in the ass
when it's a full [__] audience can
you imagine with a half an audience
that's not gonna you know
they employ [__] hundreds of people
so i doubt
it's gonna happen you know and i feel
bad because i was looking forward i
would go you know what i go see steely
dan
i don't care at this point i just want
to get entertained
so i could entertain you that's the way
to be a better entertainer
by you getting entertained you could
entertain
but whatever happens happens you know
i'll i'll
just keep listening to [__] ufo and
eddie trunk
on the radio and for entertainment you
know what i'm saying that's it yeah
that's it that's it
everybody figures out you know to get
through this but i'm optimistic man
and we were talking earlier i don't know
if it's gonna where you
you know you're going to pull where
we're going to post this where you
picked up but
i was able to get the vaccine and i got
i'm fully vaccinated now so
that that feels great man because
i mean they're saying and they've got
more research today they just said that
the via the vaccines are over 90
effective i mean it's unbelievably uh
effective for this so i feel really good
like next week i bought a place in vegas
and uh you did yeah i love vegas i
bought a place there it was always a
dream of mine
i close on it in june but i'm going out
next week to check on it because it's
being built it's a condo it's being
built
and uh now i'm i'm looking forward to
going out there and of course look
if i go someplace and they say you got
to wear a mask or whatever i'll wear the
mask
i'll play balls but but now
if i go to something or my friend owns a
restaurant there we get a couple guys
together we're all sitting down
everyone's eaten
i'm not going to be like freaked out i
mean it really feels good
to know that if you trust the science
that you've got a very slight chance
even if somebody's sitting next to you
god forbid who's got the the friggin
virus you got a pretty good chance
of not getting sick so um it feels great
you know i
i everybody makes their own decisions
what they want to do but
i can tell you that uh you know being
vaccinated and
after a year of worrying like
you know my mask below my nose is this
guy sick next to me i did some stuff on
planes
i did travel during the pandemic before
i was vaccinated i did do a few things
with a band that went out on a bus i you
know it was a little
risky but i had to take my chances
because it was a gig
a good gig um now that's like
not even in my mind i'm like i mean it's
in my mind because it's everywhere but
i'm not worried about it anymore it
feels great
for me i just i got sick and tired of
getting the calls
three days later there's a waitress
who's got covid when you went to the
restaurant
the waiter had it i got an email one day
i took my wife out to lunch they took
our emails
[__] two days later i get an email
that i gotta go take a test thank god
there's a place close to me and i
became friends with the guy the guy's a
rogan guy
so i was going in there anytime you know
i didn't want to get my producer
sick he's got children he's got parents
right so
i was as conscious as i could be you
know
i'm not gonna do but what i did what i
did was
so i when i before i was vaccinated the
little bit of travel that i did and the
little the gigs that i did do
i uh i played by the rules i did the
mask the whole thing washed the hands
did all this
all the stuff they told you to do and
then
because i got two kids and my wife and
stuff so what i did and i'm fortunate
because i've got a second house
at the beach so what i would do is i
would land
and then my wife would be like go to the
beach house i'd be there by myself i
could work from there
and i'd stay there for anywhere from
seven to ten days
to make sure that i wasn't sick and i
just go to the cbs
i test as soon as the test came back
negative i came home
so i've made sure that you know i i took
every precaution
that i could at that time so now it's
going to be nice to know i don't have to
worry about that because my wife's got
the vaccine
um even my daughter was able to get the
first dose so they're really rolling in
jersey right now
i think i mean if i can't get to
jonathan johnson i'll have to settle for
the modern and faint twice
because i usually go down twice so and i
in my mind if i faint they're gonna rape
me
so i just get these [__] wild little
[__] fantasies that
you know i hate faint and that when i go
to when i had surgery on my knee i go
i knew those [__] stuck a
finger up my ass or something
like i always feel bad passing out i
don't like passing out so
if i just gotta call joey i just got a
colonoscopy you ever get one of those
oh [__] yeah so you know they put you
down for that they give you that
propofol man you're
done you're gone two hours nice you wake
up
they won't let you leave to your fart
you're in a [__] room with 20 other
guys nelson you just hear like a
symphony of farts
you see a guy leaving they won't let you
leave to your fart
and then you just see [__] people
leaving like
they just suck the dick they're walking
out with their heads down they're
embarrassed
because you heard them [__] declaring
that noise come out of their ass
it's tremendous michael jackson that's
the [__] that michael jackson was using
to go to sleep
no he wasn't yes joey that stuff so the
stuff they put you down with
is called propofol and it's it is the
same exact stuff
when michael jackson died he had hired
the doctor that's why he had a doctor
24 7 because you need to be oxygen and
monitored
you're in and it's a general anesthesia
but it's remarkable because it's a
little syringe
it's like a milky looking substance the
minute they hit you with that in about a
minute you're
you're down you're out until they bring
you back
and that's what michael jackson was
using to sleep and i know that
because because i gotta get a
colonoscopy every three years because my
dad had colon cancer so it's a family
history thing so i'm like an old pro
i'd have in my ass you know hit with
that thing
and and the doctor said to me when i saw
the
because they kept saying with michael
jackson it was like a clear
uh it was like a a milky looking fluid
that he was being injected so i looked
at it it was like
it almost like smoked in the in the tube
and i
i said to him i go is that propofol and
he goes yeah that's what you're getting
i go
is that the stuff that michael j and he
goes oh yeah because it made big news
michael made big news with it
he goes as a matter of fact among
anesthesiologists
he goes we now don't even call it
propofol we call it jackson juice
in the medical community they call it
jackson juice but that's how
crazy this [__] guy was
tragically that he was putting himself
to sleep with general anesthesia and
that's when he didn't wake up from
because the doctor went and took a call
from his girlfriend or something forgot
to bring him back at the right time
the doctor was watching jeopardy there
was really a story like that
there was there was the story was like
the doctor like
forgot or like because you've got to
have
i mean you're going to let somebody keep
somebody down for eight hours on general
you gotta monitor the vitals and he took
he took a a call or something from his
side piece or whatever and got wrapped
up
and then that all [__] michael jackson's
sleeping
and he couldn't bring him back it's
insane
you're a [__] trip you know
everything about music
what's your beef with the grammys this
week you still mad at them
those cut suckers
i mean they don't they don't they don't
have a clue about rock music
they don't care about it they haven't
for over 30 years
from the time they gave the metal grammy
to jethro tall over metallica
that when the world laughed at them they
haven't changed since
it's random it's a joke it's a mess and
this to me
what they did or didn't do for eddie van
halen
is the greatest greatest defense in many
for rock fans on that show
i mean they don't even televise the rock
award anymore it's insane
but but to do that or or do
so little is just mind-blowing and i
don't care
i don't want to hear from the producer
oh well the family didn't want it
no no no you and i both know producers
jobs are to produce
so if somebody says hey the kid eddie's
kid says i don't want to play eruption
well you got five months figure
something else out don't mail it in and
pull a 15 second clip and throw it in
with everybody else
this is eddie van halen you don't do
that it was it was
disgraceful it really [__] is i
always see you get
hot during music awards season
because they are either that or the rock
and roll hall of fame
they [__] go they try to [__] with my
man trunk
and he's like a voter i'm a voter
look at this people will be amazed at
this hold on
so look what i got here this is like
crazy this is an official rock and roll
hall of fame ballot for this year
this is a real ballot this is like
this is what you know one of like i have
like one of a thousand votes that
determines who gets in the rock and roll
hall of fame i'm actually a voter
which i'll tell you i give them credit
because
as much as i crush them when it's
deserved for for rock music
they they came to me like i've been a
voter for like six
seven years and they said hey look do
you want to you want to
be a voter and i could have been a jerk
and been like no [__] you i'm not doing
that you guys suck but then i'm like
that would have been hypocritical
because if i want to make change and i
want to see change happen with this
thing
they're letting me have a major voice in
who gets in
so i actually got to give credit to tom
morello because he's the guy who got me
on the voting committee
and uh i've voted ever since i don't i
don't
rant p people love when i rant when we
were doing that metal show
they used to love to get me riled up
because it made for good tv
people loved it you know you and i
people love to see the big guy getting
crazy you know
crazy yeah so that my producer on that
metal show used to always say to
don and jim make sure you poke the bear
poke the bear meaning get me going get
me crazy right
it doesn't take much so so uh
but i tell people all the time i don't
do that for effect
i don't script it it's not planned i
just if it's in me it comes out and i
just
whether it's on the radio or tv or any
of the things i've done
if it's a passion and you push my button
i'm just gonna let it go
sometimes but i don't do it for a fact i
don't do it unless i feel it's warranted
and uh with the grammys lately
and and certainly sometimes the rock
roll hall of fame i mean
i'm lucky i got a voice i got a
following i got a platform i'm going to
use it
i'm happy you do because even last year
i voted
and i don't see where they come up with
these names you know i was voting for
pat benatar i grew up on pat benatar
she should have been there last week i
went to see her last year
and then the bass player told me they
were up for it don't say nothing in
front of her
you know i voted for every [__] day i
voted for her you know whatever
then she didn't get it i couldn't
[__] believe it you know i talked
about on the podcast and then she didn't
get it so
i thought there was some type of fix was
in so [__] that i moved on
you when you say you voted what are you
talking about the fan vote thing
yeah the fan vote thing it's all
[__]
i realized that after i [__] got
taken by it i realized
it's a sponsored thing and taught the
only way the fan vote comes into play
at all for the rock and roll hall of
fame is if there's a tie
so say say somebody's on the fence and
it's 50
votes 50 votes in 50 votes not in
and the fed and if that person won the
fan vote
then that would get them the other vote
to get in otherwise the fan votes
just a popularity contest it will not
get anybody in
that's great to [__] know because i
didn't know what was going on because i
know
this ballot which is what the actual
voters get
my votes on this if you can see at the
end this is where i make my selections
and mail it in
but my my my votes on this i get to pick
five each of my five votes
means more than the entire fanbook
that's how weighted it is towards the
voters
versus the fan vote the fan vote if you
notice the fan votes sponsored it's
always like
presented by some company so there's a
lot of that going on you know about
pushing people to
a brand and of course the artists love
engaging their fan bases and they love
winning it who wouldn't want to say
we won the fan vote to have the most
fans that's all great
but the reality of it is it's not
getting you in or out unless
it's the rare case where it's a
tiebreaker
eddie i'm looking forward to this summer
because uh
we're gonna get to hang out at one point
or another yeah you know jimmy has asked
me a couple times and
i just didn't wanna you know covert was
scary for everybody so i didn't want to
meet you and
give our first meeting i'm gonna give
you covet or
whatever nobody's gonna invite me over
so now that you're all
vaccinated up i'm gonna get vaccinated
up you know i put myself on a
marlborough list
uh and all the towns close to where i
live
uh hopefully we get together and talk
some more man
i'm a big fan of yours uh
you know my time zone changed so now
when i get in the car
i either get duff or tom morello i don't
get
you anymore because my time zone was
different in la
i think you come on at 2 eastern or
something
5 pacific or 4 30. so i would i would
take my daughter to kick boxing
and i would sit in the car and watch her
and listen to you
watch a kickbox you know so it was it
was great
but my time zone changed now now i never
listen to eddie trunk i'm never in the
car when that is in the [__] car
two o'clock so a lot it's live two
eastern every day on 106.
and then it replays every night 10
eastern
uh and then you can always listen though
on the app
joey uh you could always just an hour
after i'm done with the live show
there's tons of people i know that do
that they just go to the app the whole
show's there
and a little secret about the listening
on the the app the commercials are cut
out so
two hour shows like an hour 40 every day
and you can listen that way too
so there's a bunch of ways to get it if
you want to stay stay you know stay up
to
what's going on what i'm doing but i
want to tell you when we talked about
this
and uh your manager brian who's a friend
reached out to me a while ago
i would love to have you come sit in
with me on the show anytime
and just talk rock consider it we're
gonna do that no doubt
the only thing like i said to you is and
feel free to call in if you ever want to
rant about something or chime in
you're always welcome anytime just text
me i'll get you right on
but i said it's funny like
there's been over my career a lot of
uh comics that i've become friends with
because they're
rock fans are fans of what i do and i'm
a fan of what they do whatever it may be
so that's how i met donna jim to begin
with and that's how that metal show came
about years ago
and that's how we became friends because
they used to listen to me and we met at
a concert
but you know brewer and dice and all
these guys i got to know because
you know they were into rock and roll
and they come around they hang out with
me and stuff
um you know norton i mean it's there's
tons of people i can think of gas
all these guys so when i have people
like that
on who have come by it was all it's
always
so much better if you're just in the
room
and you're you're hanging out and you're
shooting the [__] like we're doing now
versus you know more of like an
interview with somebody especially if
they're just rock fans wanting to hang
out and shoot the [__]
but obviously this frigging pandemic i
mean
i'm not even allowed because of like
liability concerns and hopefully it's
loosening up
but i'm not even allowed to be sitting
like i'm in my home studio right now
where i do my show from
i've got another mic right here i can't
have them be face to face with another
person on the air yet
because they're worried about if they
get sick i get sick or whatever
so it's a weird time but i think it's
getting better
i already got some stuff lined up on the
road but as soon as that restriction
lifts
i got a mic for you right here we're
both in jersey you're 40 minutes from me
we're going to do a show we're going to
shoot the [__] and get into it
good i'm happy man yeah i'm happy you're
always trying today
i really wanted to get you on the
podcast and talk some [__] with you
i've been a fan for a long time i've
learned a lot from you
and i wanted to thank you and tell you
you're a great [__] guy
i appreciate it man jim told me for the
longest time he was saying to me
he goes to me uh you when you meet joey
he goes you're going to love joey joey's
like you he goes you guys
i'm telling you he goes trust me you're
going to meet joe he's going to be like
you know him forever he goes
you got to meet joe he said to me and
that's when i was coming down to my
place in ordly a few months ago
and i told jim because i s because he
would come down hang out with me down at
the house
and i said to him i go i'm on my way to
ortley for a few days he goes
come by uncle vinnie's uh joey's there
joey's there so i was like perfect so it
worked out great got to say hello and
yeah man i felt like a brother from the
minute i met you so anything you need
you got you you're always welcome on my
show as well if call
obviously for now we can do nothing but
a call but soon we're gonna just
we're going to be kicking it for sure
you got it but i'm going to take a ride
to the shore every wednesday with my
daughter and wife
i'm going to read i haven't been to
seaside since 1983.
you're you're close to you're an hour
probably so i'm gonna go to
all the shores so when i go to seaside
i'll give you a call
and maybe i could yeah yeah on the
boardwalk and bring your daughter and
wife will sit outside and uh
have a drink and talk anytime if i'm
there no
you're always welcome sounds good
brother thank you for taking the time
today
i know you have a busy schedule and i
love you today thank you very much
it's all good man i appreciate you
having me love you too take care of
yourself
be don't be afraid of the needle go get
the vaccination
you got it i'm going and we'll be
hanging soon man take care all right
take care have a great weekend thank you
brother
thank you joey bye-bye bye-bye all right
you bad [__] i want to thank
eddie trunk uh you know i've been a fan
of his for years so i'm very
i'm really happy he came on he always
puts a smile on my face
fellow new jersey and i want to thank
you guys for watching on a monday
morning it's april that's it
oh that's a whole new month with a whole
new set of priorities
i should be getting my covet test this
afternoon hopefully or one day this week
i'll keep you [__] posted but
before i get out of here the joint is
brought to you by
stamps.com now is not the time to be
standing online at the post office
that's why i and my wife both use
stamps.com you send letters
ship packages anytime anywhere right
from your computer
with stamps.com you get a discounted
rate from usps
ups and more stank stamps.com has saved
businesses thousands of hours
and stacks of cash my wife loves it okay
it's nice and easy you put it on the
scale
it prints out the little postage you put
on the box you put it on your balcony
bing bang boom the main man picks it up
when he delivers your mail if you're a
small business owner
stamps.com is a must-have do you
understand me
you could print us postage for any
letter any package any class mail
ship anywhere in the world straight from
your laptop
schedule a pickup and the mailman will
come to you like i
told you or drop it off yourself buy
print ship
it's that easy get discounts up to 40
percent are you listening to me
40 percent post office save up to 40
off post office rates and ready for this
one
62 off ups shipping rates
so you're not if you're not using
stamps.com
you're basically just slipping it's no
wonder why a million small businesses
already use stamps.com so stop wasting
time
let's get on the package today let's get
on the program
go to stamps.com right now it's a no
risk deal for you
use promo code joey you get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
with no long-term commitment to
contracts just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone you can see it
right there on the top of the home page
type in joey j-o-e-y that's stamps.com
promo code joey j-o-e-y stamps.com
never ever ever go to the post office
again
not that i got something at the post
though i'm just saying i'm trying to
save you time [__]
like i said earlier spring is in the air
the birds are chirping the sky is blue
women have been in the house for a year
men have been in the house for a year
they don't even know where to start but
i tell you where to start blue chew
why because let me tell you something
when you do finally hook up on whatever
dating site
or whatever you do you want to impress
them right you want them to go home and
go what the [__] was that
there was an explosion between my legs
japanese people must have dropped a bomb
between
what the [__] is going on blue chew
combats all forms of ed
what's he d erectile dysfunction when
your dick don't work like a guy like me
i'm 58 i got problems
it works if i use bluetooth my dick is
tip top magoo
it's blue chew brings you the first
chewable dick pill
this ain't no horny [__] goat weed or
snake juice
from the [__] liquor store from some
guy that's missing two front teeth
blue chew is an online prescription
service no doctors visits no awkward
conversations
and no waiting online at the pharmacy
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers takes you five minutes
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days just like that
it ships right to your door discreet
package there's no pictures of [__]
dicks
or exploding [__] on the [__]
envelope
your mailman won't know with the little
blue in your pocket you're always ready
to [__] get down you know what i'm
saying
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
prepared and shipped directly
it's a cheaper it's cheaper than the
[__] pharmacy
and saving you the doctor's visit and
the embarrassment
and the [__] eye contact all that
[__] is goes out the window
so do yourself a favor go to blue shoe
right now why are we playing games they
got a special deal for you
blue chew will give you will hook you up
for the month
for just five dollar shipping costs
that's it by using
joey at checkout so go to bluetooth.com
use promo code joey to receive your
first month
for free and start slinging dick ah
this is not what you want to do [__]
sling dick and sing and jump up and down
well this is your chance [__] go
to bluetooth.com
enter promo code joey you get your first
month free
and then tweet me and go joey i'm
slinging dick like [__] tarzan
without the [__] cape all right i
love you [__]
go to blueshoot.com promo code joey to
get the party started
listen to me it's [__] monday you're
looking at the week going what the [__]
am i gonna do with my life well it
starts tonight
you got nba basketball then you move on
to [__] tuesday you got nba
and then you got baseball then you're
like [__] what about thursday
the [__] masters
i'm sorry i had a pubic hair stuck in my
throat it's [__] the masters it's
april [__]
the best golfers in the world are down
in augusta georgia right now
getting ready to compete for that little
[__] green jacket
you want to get that green we'll get the
[__] draftkings right now
they're america's top rated sportsbook
app for a reason
you don't become top rated because you
suck they're [__] tremendous
this week they're giving you 100 to one
odds if the golfer you pick
ends up in the top 10. just pick a
[__] golf and put a dollar down
what the [__] do you got to lose you're
sitting there all day i got a dollar i
gotta die
this is it turn that one dollar into a
hundred [__] dollars pick any golf in
this week's tournament
i don't give a [__] just shut your eyes
and pick one what do you got to lose
if they finish in the top ten you get
the small [__] hundred
it's that simple if you finance oh joey
my finances are in a sand trap well
draftkings
will put you back on the [__] top all
right sign up for the draftking
sportsbook app now
choose the golfer before the tournament
tees off on thursday morning
and sit back and [__] collect that's
it you got baseball
you [__] kidding me go to draftkings
right now they're safe they're secure
and they're reliable you can draw your
funds whenever you [__] want to get
your balls licked that's it it's time
all right download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app today
right now use promo code joey j-o-e-y
when you sign up to turn a dollar into a
hundred dollars
if the guy for your choosing finishes in
the top 10 of this weekend's tournament
it's that easy i get excited because
come on guys
you blow a dollar on [__] worse
things okay
right now download the draftking sports
book app use promo code joey
turn that dollar into a yardstick for a
limited time only at draftking
sportsbook and here's the fine print
you got to be 21 older cut this [__] go
[__]
go look at grandpa's playboy and whack
off till you [__] get dizzy
and pass out new jersey indiana
pennsylvania
tennessee apply only all right new
customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com slash book
for details right now now you got a
gaming problem
i don't want you lurking around that
means you to kiss the debt call 1-800
gambler
or in indiana call 1-809 with it
but if you're ready to get down like
[__] run dmc in 85
download draftking sportsbook at now and
turn a dollar
into a hundred dollars if you pick the
golfer of your choosing
finishes in the top ten and they got
baseball and they got nba basketball
and they got dice and they got a casino
so draftkings right now drop download
it we use promo code joey and cut this
[__] you got me all aggravated on a
monday morning
the [__] needle won't even go on my
arm it'll bend right now
i want to thank eddie trunk i want to
thank all you [__]
i love you just have a great monday and
i'll see you wednesday ready to rock
[Music]
so
you